[Music]
stars are speaking out on President
Donald Trump's controversial
zero-tolerance immigration policy that
has resulted in a reported 2,000
children being separated from their
parents at the us-mexico border during a
six week period in April and May Chrissy
Teigen and John Legend were two of the
first celebs to voice their outrage
penning a letter they shared via
Instagram on the president's birthday
last week
quote John and I are outraged to see and
hear the horror stories of immigrant
families seeking asylum and refuge in
America being ripped apart due to the
inhumane policies of the Trump
administration Sara Bareilles also took
to social media tweeting quote this is
beyond inhumane on Father's Day and
Hathaway captioned this shot my dad and
I are disgusted and rocked to our core
by the current administration's shocking
decision to separate asylum seeking
immigrant families the consequence of
which is creating orphans with living
parents Sophia Bush encouraged her
followers to take action tweeting
Collier senators meanwhile Jimmy Kimmel
wrote quote I hope that our president
and his minions remember that children
should be with their parents not in
detention centers Reese Witherspoon
called the policy cruel and demora land
deplorable Alyssa Milano said the fight
for humanity is on and Ellen DeGeneres
tweeted I don't care what your politics
are we can't be a country that separates
children from their parents